hello there citizens of the reject Nation
we are here to watch the episode 7 Easter
eggs and breakdown from pull heavy spoilers
to die of course joined by my lovely friend
Andrew Gordon how are you Andrew I am doing
better than Riley and Joel but almost as
good as Ellie and hopefully as good as Paul's
gonna be if he doesn't miss another reference
like he did last week plus references pulse
guys leave a like for heavy spoilers if you
haven't done so already he's struggling have
you seen his views lately embarrassing also
um guys at shopzeroedition.com Paul has a
shirt fun guy here's an image real rejects
same website because we're partnered up together
got an exclusive Last of Us shirt as well look
at it I'm so proud of it it's such an intricate
design if you've seen Shawna the dead you kind
of get a little bit of the splicing reference
here don't worry it's not a spoiler they don't
play Playstation together at the end of this
game you're just spoiled by saying that now
people are gonna be like well now I'm expecting
them not to I know I understand how it goes guys
calm down it's a cool shirt respect it support
the channel by buying one please please I'm
begging you this is how YouTubers should
promote their merch please buy my [__]
so The Last of Us seven is now out and this
episode's filled with a ton of Easter eggs
callbacks to the game and a lot of things
that flesh out Ellie's backstory totes based
on the Left Behind DLC that saw us learning
more about what happened to her during the
time that Joe was at death's door in the game
originally after he fell off the Halls he had
a massive section where he played his hair
for about an hour and you had absolutely no
idea whether Joel was alive or dead it was
agonizing fighting through the infected to
discover what happened but yeah we find that
on the opening that he's okay you did have a
weak weight but yeah it wasn't as tense as the
hour long session I still feel like probably
by next week's episode we'll still get the we
gotta be getting at least something related
to what occurs within that hour right I mean
of course and obviously this isn't a spoiler
but if you've seen the trailers in loot to
reference to what you're saying yes we are
going to be getting I believe so yes in loot to
reference yes that's I just made up that word
but yes in reference to what you were saying
yes we will be getting that I from the trailer
yes thank you for the correction see he's not
just a my one of my best friends he's he's here
to create I'm a character of grammar he does
this too off camera he corrects me all the time
but I gotta do best here buy a shirt now when The
Last of Us Part One remake was released last year
I was thinking that they might add in the life
behind chapter so it happened in chronological
order they didn't know and sandman's the only
show I've seen come with DLC so they dropped
it in here where it should take place in the
story what about they do skip over a big part
of it dealing with Ellie searching for supplies
in the game the story was split in half and we
ended up getting two scenarios set inside a mall
yes throughout the DLC you jump back and forth
between the two and in the first you saw what we
get in the mall with Riley in the second section
it was a completely different location set in
the present where you followed Ellie as she
looked for supplies this took you to a crashed
military Chopper in the area and he found that
the mall was teaming with infected after getting
the supplies you made your way back to Joel which
is where you had to protect him from Hunters
who were out for his blood I need something
like that in the show oh I gotta have at least
10 minutes of Ellie surviving on her own and
having a takedown infected on her own or fight
some bad guys on her own like 10 minutes versus
you know hours worth of doing that and with
in the video game itself because to me that's
some of the most intense of the video game and
I feel like it would only Elevate Bella Ramsay
if they provided that I completely agree with
you we we really need to have that like that is
a very important section of the game it's not
a long extreme like major section of the game
but it is an important section of just fleshing
Ellie out more just seeing that she can't survive
on her own as well and just shows how strong and
stoic of a character she is so I really would be
really saddened and disappointed if they do not do
that in any way shape or form but I gotta imagine
they're going to I I just don't see a scenario
where at least five ten minutes of showing her on
her own showing that she can you know endure and
Survive by herself so I I'd be very disappointed
and very shocked if they don't do that yes and if
they could tone down the wokeness that'd be great
but guys buy a shirt too and buy a shirt please
we start off with a snowy abandoned neighborhood
which we learn is where Joel and Ali went to after
them all Upon returning home from hunting you saw
that Ellie had hitched up somewhere like this
and they really managed to recapture the look
of the location similar to The Source materials
if you find gel in the basement on a mattress and
Ellie's been doing DIY surgery in order to try and
heal him and now we can also catch an empty tool
rack and these have all been taken and likely
used for weapons it reminded me of the kind of
houses you'd find in the game where everything had
been picked clean because I'd been spamming the
triangle button now Jill tells me and last week
he of course wanted him to take it his worst fears
come true and he's put her in a lot of danger
and is now holding her back Joel is very much
the kind of person who would just ditch someone
who was in this position because in this world
he it doesn't really allow for hangers on as she
puts Dakota see genuine love in his eyes and he
realizes this is more than what he's had before
but there's she even said that he didn't really
love her and they were just together because they
were both good at surviving he very much sees Ali
as his second daughter though and she views him as
the father that she never had now we sort of get a
similar pot device to Left Behind and as something
new happen in that we then cut to the Past Ellie's
about to step out of the basement at this point
now he flashed back to her in a federal training
camp I know we keep pausing a lot but I gotta say
what I like about the addition of Joel being out
of it as he's dying is that in the game he's very
much just unconscious yeah and here Pedro's awake
you know he's suffering and he's like on the
verge of just passing out the whole time but I
like that you get to see him become very emotional
because he he's a master at communicating through
his eyes oh yeah which does wonders for him
when he's the Mandalorian I think uh I think
that was great to see it here yeah we can see
that she has a Walkman and this is something
that she also had in the comic uh comic and here
listening to all in on by Pearl Jam they're quite
important band in the franchise and the song
Future Days was a thing that constantly popped
up throughout at the time of part two's release it
was a big thing about how the song didn't actually
get released by the time that outbreak happened
however Naughty Dog pointed out that they'd done a
live show where they played it so the characters
could actually know this song honestly I don't
think people would have cared because it is quite
sad obsessing over this type of stuff about the
outbreak was moved forward 10 years for the show
so that song pops up yeah I'm gonna [__] kick
off a [__] furious this moment is pretty much
the academy in the comics and it's clear they
wanted to tie back to that often overlooked Last
of Us offshoot did you know there were Comics I
did know there were economics no no there were
Comics but I have not read any oh my God what
I know what elusive learning this I want to buy
some Comics I understood that reference by the
way and I understood that you should buy a shirt
while you're right I do need to get one but yeah
no I I do need to get on the comics I know I'm an
evil evil man I I don't love Last of Us enough but
I I should I really should get on the comics for
sure damn that's shocking and no oh wait and that
we saw Ellie with Riley Ross yeah she's already
left the bullies that capitalizing this and one
called Bethany rips her headphones off and taunts
her for having no one to fight her battles it's
clear Ali gravitates towards authority figures
and Riley is very much a prototype gel protector
figure we learned from Captain Kwong that she's
been acting differently the last couple of weeks
since Riley left and her friend departing is
another example of someone leaving here Ellie
never really got to know her mother she was palmed
off by Marlene test died and Jill tried to get rid
of her with Tommy you can see why she told Sam she
was tired of being alone like Al Green and I think
it's really good writing to sell the C sheets of
this in this flashback moment it's clear everyone
is ties to the past they hold on to just like
Ellie does and we see that even Captain Kwong
has trouble letting go he has a faded picture of
his family on his desk and I'm guessing he's died
during the initial outbreak now Ellie's beans
several times before and instead of punishing
her Quang wants to give her some advice He
suggests that she aims to be an officer and
demonstrates this path by throwing down his keys
the first path is a cub and the second being Keys
is symbolic because this will open up doors for
her it also added a really cool is that a naughty
dog too and we catch the naughty dog oh no way
I just noticed that a conversation in scene is
very much another side of fedra that we haven't
seen before in the game they are pretty much
always your enemies yeah those are the bandits
that you encounter along the way you press the
pause button I'm sorry no one has authority to
press this face Mark by the way buy a shirt I
do like though that they have expanded upon you
know the the military with fedra a little bit in
terms of showing from their perspective because
obviously as Paul just mentioned in the game
everything was from Joel and Ellie's perspective
and Tess as well when we were in that portion of
the game so you really just only viewed them as
the bad guys you know you realize in this show
everything's not just black and white if there is
some gray area there when it comes to fedra so I
actually do like that they have expanded on them
and just again just seeing everything from their
point of view and there is a reason why they do
the things that they do I'm not saying I I'm fully
behind everything they do but I I understand
why they do it it makes for an interesting
drama at least you know and perspective just
from seeing their point of view on the show
you press the space bar first I know I did I did
I'm so sorry no I agree it's very last of us too
to be doing it however this Series has shown
things from that point of view because in the
game we will lock to Joe and Ellie's perspective
really shows you all these kinds of points of
views and it allows you to actually sympathize
with them Huang believes that fedra is the only
thing holding the world together and that if they
go down the world will fall apart in Kansas City
we saw things were like a federal house did and
the people there were carrying out murders and
just doing horrible things Federer also helped to
push the infected underground there and Kathleen's
need for Revenge unleash this on her people now
in her room we catch some dinosaur drawings and
also a picture of some moon cycles we'll go over
what these are two things being Ellie's interests
are very very important we also get to know pun
intended book by Will Livingston and her life
is just slightly below it out of view this is
actually volume one or as we see Riley busting
out Volume 2 later on this is a a slight change
up from the game as in those they found it in
the mall when coming across A hermits Camp Riley
then read it as you made your way through or as
yeah she has it already oh I got something else
and in the game that goes on for a very very long
time and I loved every second of it yeah no
I love that they give you that option in the
game like you can either like stop listening to
the pun jokes or you can keep going and yeah I
always every time I play I'm like no I want to
keep hearing them they got so much in there and
it's cool that they draw a parallel with that in
the relationship with Joel of carrying that over
you know I think that's really makes it stronger
absolutely it helps you know just bring the bond
together for sure between the two absolutely
buy shirt you also catch Charlie reading a
Savage Starlight comic which I think is titled
negentrippy Nugent trippy anyway I don't know
episode 5 video we talking about how these were
Collectibles I eat pick up in the game and again
trippy issue was something that he came across on
your travels we see the inside of it being a big
action scene involving a man and a woman bursting
their way into somewhere probably reaching uh but
I think this is very much how Ali views her and
Joel and the guy in the book even looks slightly
similar to how he does in the game doesn't he well
he is sure either way sure [Music] well that's not
too long until she returns but we get another
tour of her room and see some tapes the top one
by aha foreshadows a great moment in the second
game near the James one plays into this episode
later on I got you babe it's a song we hear Riley
and Ellie dancing to at the end and this music
was also what they jammed away to in the mall on
Riley's fate for last night you also see a poster
for Mortal Kombat I just played that in an arcade
the other day I saw his alien Joel came across a
cabinet for it which in the game was a fighter
called the turning it started a character called
Angel knives but with the show being a Warner
Brothers property they have the rights to use the
Mortal Kombat characters I think that the game
developers likely knew this was going to be an
Easter Dragon advance and in the recent Last of
Us remake they actually added in a Mortal Kombat
sticking her hand over Ali's mouth
this is slightly different to the game
is of course foreshadowed her fate and
let's play the scene side by side so you
can see what they kept and also
what they changed I love these
I would have pretended
[Music]
Riley
laughs now Riley owl
I landed on my hip what the hell I thought
I Was Bitten I know it was kind of Awesome
[Music]
you're not gonna kill me are you
see you and I don't even know how
long 45 days well 46 technically so
is it going I thought you were dead on for
three weeks wanna know what I've been up to
I'm I thought you were dead are you okay I'm fine
I just ran away for a bit that's all here look
no way where were you
I joined the Firefly oh [__] you
you're a firefly
you're a firefly Jesus are we cool
I disappeared and you're mad
and I owe you an explanation
let's get out of here and I'll tell you
all about it we'll tell you everything
first you have to promise me something it's
almost morning and I have military drills
you know where we learn how to kill
fireflies not going anywhere with
you it's great it's 2 A.M in a few hours I have
drills fireflies put some pants on and let's go
grass
so there are some slight changes there but lots
of similarities too I do like that for the show
they chose to play with a more immediate intensity
versus the way how Riley kind of is in the game
is she seems to be trying to brush off anything
that's serious whereas the actress plays into the
fact like no I got some like something concerning
and serious that I will be telling you a little
bit later which works whereas the Riley in the
game is kind of concealing that side of herself
and is just trying to play off like no we're just
gonna have a good time that's all that matters
today we're just gonna have a good time like
I don't want you to think about the fact that
I'm leaving we're just gonna have a good time you
know yeah and also the way they play into Ellie's
passion with aligning herself with fedra and
Riley's passion for aligning herself with the
fireflies that is a starting point for their
dynamic in the show where as you even see here
Ellie doesn't seem too perturbed by it you
know I like both versions uh the video game
how she pretends to bite her and then in this
one where she kind of just covers her mouth in
a more serious uh way but I personally like the
video game one just a little bit more where she
snuck up on her and tried to bite her just I
don't know because I I just love that aspect
of their relationship they're very joking with
each other and there were certain things again
that I liked in the video game a little bit more
whereas here I thought there were some interesting
and better choices that they made in the TV show
but again they both worked for me Riley is now
a firefly and he should not still ahead of the
map but picking up the sort of Romeo and Juliet
Vibes here with them being on opposite sides
in the game as you're cutting between timelines
he join alien Riley jumping into an abandoned
Apartment block which is why here trucks outside
[Music]
that was close huh however here we
see them very much moving through
the streets as trucks travel through
looking for people breaking curfew
eventually go down into an Alleyway
and then into this which is when they
bust out the torches at least doesn't
work and she has to hit it time to time
in the game we learned how Riley became a firefly
which I'm gonna play with the show version so you
can see how things slightly differ remember that
Firefly you bet installed his gun yeah I remember
him that's Trevor I saw him walking down the
street so I tailed his ass one night you were in
the hole I got bored so I snuck out I follow him
into this alley and all these fireflies Ambush me
they took me right to their Hideout to Marlene
I was on my way back being stealthy like I am
and this chick popped out of nowhere chick
like our age no like 40. were you scared
terrified I thought this time she would actually
shoot me but instead she just says what took you
so long whatever anyways old she said she was
impressed watching me sneak around avoiding
guards she was expecting me and she just made
you a firefly something like that and she asked
what I thought about fedra so I told her the
truth their fascistic bags and they're the ones
that should be getting hanged for their crimes
that hole almost killing me thing was a test
she wanted to know I was committed oh she's
like all right do you want in you're in
that's it I'm in the show the woman she's
talking about is clearly Marlene who recruit
her personally or as in the game she was brought
to her makes it seem like Marlene's been keeping
an eye on Ellie for a long time and that she's
now has those around her too eventually if she
had someone on her side that was close to Ellie
Ellie would be warmer to her and it also explains
why her fireflies didn't immediately kill Ellie
when she was bitten Moline has a close attachment
with Ellie very good safe and knowing Riley might
have helped with that however it could also be the
reasoning why she shipped Riley off as she didn't
want her running away with her friend we discover
later on that Riley actually asked if Ali could
join her but Marlene said no she just wanted to
keep her in the qz and potentially they may have
moved Riley for that reason now in the apollon
block they also find a guy who seemingly overdosed
on pills Ali and Joel of course come from the same
QC that's possible even sold him these as they
are similar to what we saw him dealing in episode
one ironic with Abby if in some ways they've
already cross paths via pills pills they unite
everyone they bring everyone together enough to
change the name of the show The Last of the pills
no the last of the shirts no I'm failing guys it
could be teasing the danger that Joel has around
him and how his actions have a negative effect on
people now a body lying against the wall like this
is also somehow very much foreshadows infected
later on most of those that have quarters yeah
body and growing out their face and they'd
eventually hit a point where they knew they
were going to die if they didn't become full-on
clickers thus they'd head to a wall lay down die
and grow into it and in the games they'd spread
out spores the other one in the mall isn't dead
he's very much following the same pattern and the
body against the wall here at least so haunting
it collapses through the floor and they take
his boots with them and drink it on the roof
Ali pretends to love it and this is a complete
opposite of the campfire scene in which he sped
it straight out she's trying to impress Riley
and we do see a different side to her here for
Christ's sakes Paul in the game there's a
drinking moment that brought this up the
last video what are you doing man I'm gonna play
some of the clip here's some of the clip awesome
sure sure oh oh my god oh here it's disgusting see
it's the one thing I have to hold on to that was
a good reference in the Easter egg that well you
caught I mean I I noticed it too right away but
yeah yeah way to toot your own horn I'm the one
who said it yeah I mean at least he kind of still
mentioned the drink but yeah no I I feel you it's
in the game yeah it is it's in the game wasn't it
mentioned I don't understand Paul now we learned
that it's not the first Dead buddy Riley scene and
that she's witnessed her parents corpses most of
the kids take it in by fedra were orphans and this
allowed them to train the kids to be soldiers if
you have ties to your family and stuff you're less
likely to be loyal to things like fedra especially
when they're oppressing the very people you're
connected with Jedi can't work that way too well
he's gone and we then see our obsessing over it
this is something she's done throughout the series
and Neil lure of power means a lot to her as she's
not really experienced the bad side of it at this
point they talk about fedra and also the fireflies
Riley sees them as fascist whereas Ellie sees
them as holding everything together Riley thinks
the fireflies are gonna bring freedom but we've
already seen from Kathleen the kind of thing it
leads to yeah she ended a promising Fair trials
that people would live if they gave up others
and in the end this was shown to all just be a
lie Pedro also do terrible things too think what
it boils down to is that no matter what happens
the worst traits of humanity will always emerge
in some form or another no matter decide we gotta
keep order man good sides too and obviously these
sides have their appeals as well in the end though
whichever side is in charge will oppress the other
side in some form and thus we get these divisions
that lead to others attempting to seek power when
they finally get it they want to punish you
the side who now become the oppressed ones
and the cycle starts again Riley later brings
up how fedra have stopped people and in the
game when he got to Pittsburgh you found graffiti
talking about how the people there were famished
Ellie said it didn't hover the fireflies bomb the
storage Depot which Riley sees as being propaganda
hit up any social media site you're gonna
see people talking about the faults in
the other political side whilst dismissing
their own I think Ellie and Riley show we
can find common ground with stuff like this
so Trump and Biden supporters can get along
Paul just taught me that Paul just unified an
entire I mean he missed a big reference in last
episode but he just might have unified an entire
country that's right guys that's what Paul's all
about unifying unifying it's time to make this
an alt-right Channel [Laughter] now Riley says
that the fireflies don't carry out attacks when
civilians are involved but tell that to test
and Robert now in the game there was an extra
Dimension to this as there was an announcement
that said there hadn't been an affection for 30
days Riley said this was a lie and that it was
just covered up I kind of I was hoping that this
would appear in the show as we of course saw Joel
having to burn lots of bodies in episode 1. this
scene does kind of mimic the game a bit as your
first run along rooftops before coming alongside
the mall like what we have here the pair then
dropped down through a collapsed roof and they
enter the Liberty Gardens Mall this is the same
as what the location is called in the game and
they do rearrange things slightly originally you
saw the tunnel one it's poster which was a water
pistol I used against Riley during one of the
pairs final scenes together it was the game across
a 10 for a man named Winston who he learned had
been living in the mall as recluse as I mentioned
earlier he was who you got the pun bug from and
you learned that he died of old age in this world
that's a big thing as there's it's very much
survival of the fittest so making it to that point
really means a lot and Winston's also where they
got to drink from I actually was waiting for him
to say that I was like oh he's gonna bring it up
right now I really do think though I mean again I
I pointed this out at the end of the last episode
one thing that really bothered me in the episode
again I I love the episode overall they were not
doing a very good job of sneaking right they were
being Extremely Loud and again I get it for the
audience we need to hear what they're saying in
terms of dialogue and audio I I get that but you
still be in a quiet tone and we can still be able
to hear them whereas if you're talking loud and
we're sneaking around with fedra around it's not
going to be I'm not going to be able to suspend my
disbelief as much for that and it's I'm gonna get
now a little more on the nitpicky side when it's
done throughout the entire sneaking about so that
got a little bit under my under my skin as as you
can tell but not as much as you with the drink
but I still agree with you he's got to mention
the drink lazy bum now from here you went to the
Halloween shop and then you threw some bricks at
some call Windows to see who could smash the most
what the winner smash the like button as well and
then from here the characters turned the power on
and went on the Merry-Go-Round here though they
flipped the power on first before they head into
the mall so turns out the whole city has power
they just flipped the circuit breakers
all you gotta do is flip it back
so turns out when Federer connected that block
up to the grid this place got connected too not
that they know now at this point we got a
scene that's very reminiscent of the game
with Ellie opening up a door into the
mall in which we see it all light up
we also have a play on the escalator
scene which pulls directly from that
whoa look at me
this is the first Wonder on the day
now and from here we catch a poster
for dawn of the wow yes I was gonna
point that out too but did he just
not mention the song or is that in
the spoiler spoiler section later on
look Paul we're making a list of everything
and we're coming for you buddy this is yeah
we're just watching this video to see what you
missed yeah we we are the YouTube comments you
put hours of work into a video and we're here
to only tell you the couple of things yeah you
might have skipped over my Curtis invite the
two this was a fictional My Life in The Last
of Us universe and here's what they had to
say about it in the game dragged you to see
that movie everywhere I saw this not before the
outbreak he did he totally get her by the end
nobody gets gutted it's a it's a dumb
team movie who dragged you to see at them
I don't know always has his guard up stay focused
all right I also love the little back in five
minutes sign and it shows just how much people
were caught off guard you're right I'm good I
know she likes to clear your mouth on to throw it
on camera yes I do it's sometimes you sniff you
go let's find anything in that I'm so glad I'm
so glad we're pointing this out to the internet
something that more to make fun of me because
falling asleep on camera wasn't enough in the last
year wait what when did you fall asleep on camera
on your brother's Channel that's what happens at
the Javi KOA channel the guests fall asleep
not here got too much G fuel keeping us alert
take that jabby this guy just popped out
for a poo and didn't end up coming back
everything happened really quick but
Footlocker and probably also get loads
of toilet paper yes again added a lingerie
scene with Ellie trying to Smart herself up
after Riley makes a joke about imagining her
in it from here we go to the Merry-Go-Round
which pulls directly from the PlayStation
classic it's probably the most memorable
part of Left Behind and in the game it's
chewing this that Riley gets out the pun
book symbolically merry-go-rounds are a sign
of innocence and simplicity that puts horrified
so they're often used as sources of magic and
adventure and carousels like this are commonplace
at amusement parks as they bring joy to lots of
people this is just the pair enjoying what for
their missile last night on earth before a major
change happens though Ellie doesn't know it Riley
is well aware he's meant to be going away and
either way Ellie is about to lose her forever
now similar what happens in the game The Ride
breaks down and it spoils the moment the phone
is cut short very much foreshadowing the journey
that plays ahead and we discovered that Riley was
about to turn 17 and that she'd been assigned
to sewage detail this is all that Quang thought
she was good for and you can see why she ended up
running away racist Fred ran the duties assigned
to people were very much prisons themselves and in
this world people didn't really have the freedom
to do what they want no one was lucky enough to
just sit around talking about movies all day and
you can see why people gravitate towards the
promise of freedom and Liberation now on the
merry-go-round in the game Riley busts out the
pun book but here they kind of skip over it save
it for later and just go straight to the photo
booth the show being set 10 years earlier does
mean that they can't bring send things over and in
the game it ended Facebook if you wanted to share
your photos to Facebook neither knew what that
was and instead he got printouts of the photos
before the whole thing shut down in a nice fourth
wall breaking moment you could actually share the
photos you made in game to your own Facebook and
that was an oh really sensation explaining to my
dad why I was posting pictures of you who are
those two girls like what um we get the little
bunny mascot however the names changed up because
of the whole Facebook thing the game has it being
called sharesnap or as the show is star shot
because they couldn't have posted it online with
it being said in 2003 yeah Facebook wasn't around
then and it's genuinely one of my favorite Easter
eggs in the entire show and I love when they put
this much thought into it now from here they go
into the arcade we see machines for Tetris Frogger
attack from Mars and Daytona USA there's no shot
for shot with the to see the scene with the with
the taking the photos it's so it's so similar
it's like almost identical look it's
not like you you missed something but
lazy lazy Paul hours of work wasted this was about
driving across the country which may be a link to
Joel and Ellie doing it as as 2C said also in the
game Ellie jumped into Jack and Daxter machine and
naughty dog of course made that game also worth
pointing out that Ellie's wearing the shirt that
we saw her wearing in episode 1 and this was
also the show that Young Nathan Drake brought
in Uncharted three anyway in the show Ellie gets
to play Mortal Kombat 2 whereas in the game The
Turning cabinet didn't actually work instead Riley
described the game and he was the most memorable
part for me yeah I'm guessing Naughty Dog didn't
have the resources to design The Mechanics for a
fighting game for what amounted to about two
minutes in the game but here we catch them
playing it out they go to the Deadpool stage and
a Deadpool is when you bet on who's gonna die but
my entire house on Riley and now moving to Vegas
baby I still do prefer the video game yeah yeah
it feels more intimate you know especially for the
connection that they're building yeah like this is
more relatable is way more relatable to be bonding
over this in that regard but yeah just using the
imagination because I I remember playing that
part and getting swept up in it myself yes and
then I'm I'm imagining it with her because it's
like he feels like a little cringy and Goofy at
first and then you get lost in it and you're like
oh this is effective and you are creating a memory
together I agree with you it's much more relatable
for us but I I love the vivid imagination not only
you know that neo-druckman and the writers came
up with in the game but I just like again just
showing the bond and like Riley like I don't care
what the situation is I'm gonna find a way to help
Ellie and cheer her up in this moment and let her
get his imagination yeah yeah but get the feeling
of playing the game even if it doesn't work it
just showed like Riley has a certain level of
you know going to whatever extreme she needs to
to make sure she she helps and pleases her friend
and I just thought it was really interesting and
Broad and really delicate cool choice that they
chose to do that same like because I remember
the first time playing that scene like I don't
know how this is gonna work like just imagine
the character and then has the scene like kept
on going I was like this is really freaking cool
yeah I love this it's strong yeah and then every
time I played him like I'm like really looking
forward to this part again because I'm not I
love that part that's great and it shows them
as like their children using their imaginations
to escape and I think a big part of survival of
survival instincts oftentimes if you're a child
it has to be a Survivor oftentimes a great way
of escapism is using your imagination so I liked
having that be implemented for the characters and
I feel like you kind of detract that I mean of
course you haven't played the game you're not
gonna give a [__] yeah of course yeah this
is straight up just a flashback only whereas
in the game it's a cross between a flashback
and also in present time she's looking as Paul
mentioned earlier she's looking for the medical
supplies for Joel to uh you know sew him back up
with his wounds so in the University of Eastern
Colorado mall so yes yes thank God you specified
it anyway Riley chooses my Lena and she pulls off
her fatality which Ellie described her as doing
back in episode three there's this one character
named Molina who takes off her mask and she has
monster teeth and then she swallows you whole
and bursts out your bones you should get the Liu
King fatality into one of the infected who's been
awakened by the lights coming on and all the
noise he's located in a toy shop and this is
very much a symbol of Innocence which he ends up
destroying we see two dolls here and this could be
a reference to the two mannequins in the closed
shop stand which is where the attack happens in
the game yeah they just shrink it down so that it
happens in the Halloween store rather than them
going there I think the change from mannequins to
dolls again is to hammer home this creepy factor
and also the idea that this is Ellie's childhood
being destroyed as things drastically change
from this point onwards she's no longer under the
production of fedra and is basically made to flee
the qz with Joel now from here Riley takes Ellie
to Macho Nacho this is another great night dog
Easter egg and in inside Nate asked Elena if she
actually used to work there you came across this
in the morning as well and now they've brought
across the show where O'Reilly was camped out
at that's the fun book comes out and we hear the
ones which all to show up in the game what did
the frustrated cannibal do frustrated
cannibal threw up his hands [Music]
laid on me he threw up his hands what did the
triangle say to the circle you're pointless what
did the triangle say to the circle pointless you
oh in the back Ellie discovers that Riley's been
making explosives and that she was actually posted
here by the fireflies these look identical to some
of the weapons you get in part two and as Ellie
goes over you can see that on the top shelf there
is a federal container they likely were gonna
deliberate using guerrilla warfare to take them
out Riley promises Ali that they wouldn't be
used on her but there's absolutely no way that
Riley could guarantee that say Ellie did become
an officer then she would be the kind of person
they target and we see how people are very much
forced to go against each other I like the game
we learned this is our last night in Boston and it
plays off the back of this scene Ellie I'm leaving
they've asked me to leave leave what Boston
I'm supposed to join a group in another city
they're sending me to a
post in the Atlantic cutesy
I argued with them to stay here I asked
if you could so we could go together
you know how Marlene is nothing's easy
with her everything's a test but Marlene
said no the [__] is Marley Marlene is
the lady that helped me it doesn't matter
they're picking me up tomorrow tonight's my
last night in Boston why did you bring me here
I wanted to see you
because I wanted to see you
no why did you bring me here
I don't know now the Atlanta QC is always
something we hear about in the game when
you're in Pittsburgh Pittsburgh was a city
that had overthrown Federer and we discovered
that some of the remnants ended up fleeing and
going to Atlanta in a Halloween store we see
a decoration popping out of a grave and this is
similar the creature bursting out of the coffin
in the game counterpart Riley gives her the pun
Buck explaining first about it and she talks about
the doubt that she has going with them however
Riley says because Ali never had a family she
doesn't understand even with the bad you still
accept people and later on when Joel becomes
his surrogate father she very much accepts all
looking bad things in him Ali's being put through
the ringer and she goes through how Riley left her
gave her this amazing night and is then leaving
her again I think Ellie gets so attached to people
that she's willing to let them walk all over her
to some extent and believe their lies because
it's easier than losing them Riley says she's
sure about leaving and Ellie says that she'll miss
her which is when Riley gives her a werewolf mask
whilst Riley gets a clown one the characters
wore both these masks along with he ended up
doing her best role in the werewolf one which was
a really fun way to start off the mold section
which is when he had a water pistol fight using
the typhoon Blitz which he saw a sign for early
on after this Riley put the tape on and he
danced on top of the table like what we get
here it's side by side time and just be aware
that we've muted the music here for copyright
reasons a bit awkward but that's YouTube so really
quick you already noticed playing the DLC on that
Super Soaker fight hmm try not to spoil there's
a fight in part two with another woman you know
what you thought I'm talking about there's only
one other woman she fights yeah yeah I know what
you're saying now I know and it kind of reminded
me of that in a way except you know not as violent
or as intense and not with water no this is but
it's like that's kind of setting the ground for
that that's an interesting uh or foreshadowing
that you picked up there because I never even
thought about that but yeah no because that's the
only other time she fights someone with a stage
like that you know what I'm saying people who
played the game for you without going into too
much spoilers yeah I mean once we get into the
spoiler Talk part you I guess we can get into
that nah we'll save it I'm over it we'll save
it for season two save for season five [Music]
sorry but really come here
[Music]
what is it don't go what's wrong
the DLC I first played this one
I impressed myself when she said that
yeah yeah got flowers in the spring yeah
I'm sorry it's good
what do we do now [Music] we'll
figure it out what do we do now
but I don't think Marlene's gonna wait
[Music]
I like in the game the moment is ruined by the
infected one thing I have criticized the show
for is that I think they kind of missed out on
the bigger infected moments from the game such
as the skyscraper and the hotel basement sections
this was another way they lessened it a bit and
removed the Panic of running through the mall
the chase ended with it seeming like he got out
but the scaffolding fell and Ellie plummeted down
Riley jumped back down and this was very much a
giving up her life to save Ellie yeah she ends up
saving her as well but to me the impact of having
her jump back into the fire is kind of lessened
a bit now we did go back and forth at the Kevin
spoilers office over why they changed it to the
one infected and our editor Matt actually said
that she wouldn't have been as scared of The
Horde in episode 5 if she'd already seen one
that was the first time this version of Ali
experienced it and therefore it wouldn't have
made sense if she'd seen one before personally
I think it's just a budget thing and having to
film a Chase through a mall would obviously cost
and you'd have to loot more than Footlocker to
get that back should call it loot Locker not the
time of place I mean yeah I feel like it might
ultimately come down to budgetary restraints I
mean it's more effective in the in this in the
game for the fact of you're running and running
and running away and you think and it's like you
think you got this cathartic release where
oh I've escaped I've done it and then you're
like oh never mind right so you you do have that
effect but I think this does Hammer home a little
bit more of the physicality of the weight of just
what it's like dealing which is one of these guys
and they're two young girls you know so they're
not like physically the strongest of taking on
it's a more realistic situation where they can
just take on one as opposed to running away from
several but again understand the situation
of the stress of it but again I agree with
you but and I understand like we had just gotten
this incredible horde and action sequence where
they showed so much so I can imagine a lot of
the budget went towards that in terms of using
affected for their action sequences so I I truly
understand why but I think too like you just said
I kind of like that they did just show one because
again it shows how hard it is just to defeat one
of them and again like you said it's it's two
little girls so I mean it makes sense honestly
anyway back in the present Ellie guys have
another house and desperately searches for
something to help Joe shout out to all my Gamers
who know what it's like hammering that triangle
button constantly as you open up every draw for
a bit just a little bit of cloth or something now
the frustrationally has here is married in the
past without lashing out in anger and smashing
the glass like it's a button with a thumbs up
on it we get a similar shock composition to the
game and in the end Riley makes a pack that
they just lose their minds together [Music]
okay [Music] thank you
I love Riley's reaction there's some
more stuff over there you can break
there's more stuff over there you can breathe
wait I see it we got two options the way
I see him we've got two options option one
you take the easy way out one to take
the easy way out it's quick and painless
I'm not a fan of option one I
know I don't like option one
two we fight fight for what
we should just keep going we're gonna
turn into one of those things [Music]
there are million ways we
should have died before today
and a million ways we can die before tomorrow
but we fight for every second we get to spend
with each other I love that cut back in the game
two minutes
two days I don't want to give that up
whether it's two minutes or two days
we don't give that up left behind I don't want
to give that up my vote [Music] let's just wait
it out you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together it's beautiful I can
[__] oh it's option three what's option three
sorry
that really Ramsay [__] really made it their
own and they really they really killed it
really did sorry I'm sorry
let's get out of here yeah
it was not mimicking in any way
yeah it really made it their own
foreign [Music]
this is also a line reference in the game
by Ellie when she discusses her past Boston
back when I Was Bitten I wasn't alone
my best friend was there she got bit too
we didn't know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out you know we can be
all poetic and just lose our minds together
also did a bit of deep digging and the mall in the
game was apparently built in 1968 with the show of
course starting off in that year now back in the
presents make sure you sanitize that mate yeah
it's been been sat in a draw for 20 years probably
probably causing infection never mind then you go
but clearly Ellie is fine this is clearly because
she lost Riley she doesn't want to repeat of that
and she very much mirrors Jill not wanting to go
through losing his daughter again they found each
other and someone to fight for and we end with
Ali stitching up his wound in order to stop the
bleeding this shot is framed to marry the ending
of last week's episode and whereas that was a
tower now to finish on this is a more hopeful that
closes out the episode and before we get into the
spoiler section of the video I thought I'd give
my thoughts as a standalone thing I did enjoy this
adaptation of the Left Behind DLC but I don't know
if I'm a bit too close to the game yeah I think so
we were saying comparison and was just hoping
things like The Horde and the the winter Mall
sections would have been carried across I think
at this point I'm kind of just accepting that the
series will always just strip back the game so
it mainly focuses on the human moments anything
that leaves stuff being so repetitive at points
though and every episode other than four and six
I believe basically introduces one or two new
characters and they then kill off at the end so
it is all good to be fair but I think this formula
almost stops it from being great those first five
episodes especially were Classics but the last
two have kind of dropped for me personally still
good oh I love sex feel the constraints of the
series are starting to show a bit now stormery did
a really good job as Riley and though I probably
sound like I'm bashing it I do think that viewed
in a vacuum that this episode's really good I
just think of this show as a whole it needs a bit
more variety from the formula that we're getting
maybe I am too close to the game like I said but
it never really felt like they were following
a format or if they were then it wasn't clear
from that initial playthrough anyway if you're
loving this show and everything that it does
and hopefully you can at least see things from my
point of view and if you haven't played the game
no I hate you you know we're lucky that we have
both these two adaptations and and there were
there's definitely going to be people who are like
well I prefer the game and people who are like I
prefer the show so yeah everyone's gonna have that
oh you're supposed to be the unifier we want boobs
how much I love the game and and all the stupid
little references I mean he unified Republicans
and Democrats or Joe Biden supporters and Donald
Trump supporters really but you can't get video
game and TV shows coward British coward are there
people who've played the game who would say that
they prefer the show I've not met plenty of people
who are like who are who played the game and love
the show and I met people who haven't played the
game and loved the show but I I don't I haven't
met someone yet who's like I think you know season
one ends but so far I think I might like the show
more I haven't met someone who feels that way
I've Just Seen over resounding positive feelings
towards the show I haven't really seen too many
I only like the game the show is CR I have rarely
have ever seen that so definitely heard that oh
no I'm not saying I had I have two people yeah I
just said it I just said it's rare I'm not saying
I have not heard it at all it's internet you're
gonna hear I mean some negativity but yeah it's
it's been resounding positive but yeah I just
I haven't met anyone yet who's like I preferred
the show so far I mean I feel like there's things
the show has done better yeah definitely for sure
anyway that takes to the spoiler section and that
yeah we have a couple of things that I heavily
into part two red planet most of the items in
Ali's room have a payoff down the line and at one
point we catch those dinosaur drawings Cycles in
the arcade Ali also asks if the next surprise
is a dinosaur and these all tie together for
where gel takes her on her birthday the pig got
to a museum and this is filled with dinosaurs
and that's the one that Ali ends up getting
into being through that a number of times so
sorry we're constantly repeating it but they also
referenced it around the campfire last week for
sure yeah tape and take on me playing in the mall
returns in a big moment during part two as well
it's a great vision and I wanted to
play it in the video but we got hit
with copyright claims so I can't but I'm
gonna serenade you with it now as we Fade
Out so click you've got to either listen to
me or click a video on the end screen talking
[Music]
it's okay [Music]
thank you take me
[Music]
I was not expecting that that was beautiful
beautiful huh light on the super spoilery
section today but that was a great way to end it
ah another fantastic video Paul another despite
the fact that you obviously hate this show
based off what you said there there's only
one way to take it you either love it or
hate it and I um it's pretty obvious you
obviously hate it this show is the Last Jedi
for him you do have the best breakdowns on
it I'm saying it saying it loud and proud today
despite the drink thing despite the drink thing
freaking thing you keep missing buddy you're
going down Paul anyway guys follow Andrew on
Twitter and Instagram at agor711 you can catch
him on the jabic away Channel falling asleep and
here he's wide awake just with some sniffles and
clearing of the throats let's send this with a
Brandon Benzie how long have you been a patron
of ours Andrew I want you to take a guess for
how long he's been a patron of ours go ahead I'm
gonna go with how many years I've known you so
it's been eight years a minute ago eight years you
think Brandon benzie's been a patron yes I'm gonna
that we have not had the patreon that long but
that's a hell of a guess you want to do round two
all right let's go with four years four years all
right here it is uh I was close less than a year
very close but you've been you're you're one year
anniversary is coming up for us in in five months
my dude at a little less than five months and I
hope you're still around here in those five months
so what I want you to do buddy is if you can just
send me a message and answer me three questions
three questions here it is one what other Patron
accounts are you pledged to I hope it's the answer
is done two have you seen the jabby COA Channel
if so what are your thoughts it better be negative
three who's your favorite guest on this channel
if you say this guy I know you're just pandering
Brandon thanks for being here for so long and
showing your support I hope you also uh increased
your pledge all for this great shout out but you
know you can do instead of increasing that pledge
I sure you could use that money to buy a shirt
love you Brandon Benzie thanks
for being here cowboy [Music]